ok go
ok
c'est la première fois vous êtes réunis
sur un plateau de télévision en jeu
lazhar est cool mon but c'est le hasard
pour semer tournez manège en sang vous
devez venir il ya trois semaines
voyez le mariage tout ça est occupé
voilà qui en sort un film donc ces voix
là bas c'est tombé comme ça c'est tombé
comme ça vous n'allez pas faire le début
d'une mission ils auraient donc oui oui
on a fait ça avec laurent gerra et
mathilde seigner a fini de se séparer en
même temps mais je n'étais pas très
élégant vous appelle anne jarre ou anne
parillaud impériaux jarre am paris au
jard j'ai entendu l'interview vérif la
juste avant il est formidable s'il a
aucun défaut et jean-michel 25 web il a
jamais fait un coup tordu et une
gonzesse
si l'entente avec la matière parce que
entre temps ma 6 décembre
non mais des formidables et argent
mail de florent pagny est ce que vous
êtes mariés pour les impôts parce que ça
change oui oui et demi par non jean
michel vous qui êtes habitué à
rassembler des millions de gens si tu y
es pas déçu quelques 350 personnes à
votre mariage
il y avait moi il n'avait moi c'était
intime alors respectez moi il y en a
dans de petits comiques - oui mais
beaucoup moins l'année dernière il avait
la janis est déclaré dans la presse que
vous lui aviez promis le mariage avant
de la tromper avec anne vous avez
regretté
vous l'avez d'ici d'ailleurs cet étalage
de votre vie privée dans la presse
pipole
un an plus tard vous épousez anne et
vous fait la couverture de paris match
est-ce qu'il ya pas un petit souci enfin
c'est pas un truc perso une variante je
sais pas ça je pense que
qu'effectivement à partir du moment où
on aider des gens public on est exposé à
être poursuivie ce qu'est ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a beaucoup vécu depuis depuis un
an d'un an et demi et que la rétention à
tout prix de ce sens n'est pas n'est pas
non plus une solution
donc au bout du compte je pense que
s'exposer c'est aussi se protéger il ya
beaucoup réfléchi mais quand c'est
isabelle adjani qui raconte ses malheurs
dans match vous trouvez que c'est une
atteinte à la vie privée
on fait ça n'a rien à voir avec ça non
la différence c'est de mettre en cause
des gens en racontant des choses qui ne
sont pas vraies et en mettant en cause
en particulier des gens qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les protagonistes
c'est à dire ma famille mes enfants j'ai
terrain avec qui elle est aujourd'hui
isabelle adjani oui tu vas pas me croire
ouais
alors est-ce que je vous pose une
question que j'ai vu l'article dans
match demande si vous allez vérifier les
titille on vous a donné à aller lire
avant publication
il ya écrit ils ressemblent à des gosses
indécrottable gallopin qui nous font
rêver d'éternelle jeunesse c'est beau à
l'écrit bien ouais
oui et non décrit très bien alors anna
vous avez déclaré dans l paris lorsque
je les ai vus en parlant de jean michel
j'ai su que c'était lui bah oui jerhinat
je tiens c'est vrai c'était quand la
première rencontre c'était l'année
dernière début 2004 au milieu de mille
quatre vingt dans le premier semestre
2004 vous êtes entré comment s'en
contrefoutent des amis communs qu'elle a
mis ça on va justement le garder pour
nous est utile et vous avez senti que
c'était jean-michel quoi hein vous le
connaissiez quand même il est connu jean
michel proposé la tenue ce jour là non
mais je crois que bon on peut on peut on
peut voir les choses comme ça mais
effectivement toutes les toutes les
rencontres sont des rencontres qui au
fond
ce sont toujours les mêmes jusqu'à ce
qu' il y en a une qui soit
fondamentalement différent mais j'avais
le même coup de foudre est bon pour
c'est pas un coup de pouce est une
évidence donc ce n'est pas un coup de
foudre c'est d'une certaine manière le
contraire d'un coup de foudre le contrat
de quelque chose qui se consume et c'est
au contraire elle quoi voilà ça c'est ça
c'est le mot on va dire que c'est le
bourg reconnaissance exactement
vous allez faire le troisième mariage
quelle erreur elle a évité cette fois
pas de lutter déjà non laura georges dia
va continuer je pense que je pense que
quand on est je pense que quand on quand
on se marie léglise c'est une dimension
totalement différente et que moi j'ai
pas du tout l'impression de vivre le
mariage commun comme un carcan et en une
comme une obligation au contraire comme
une libération et si on parle de la
fidélité pense que la fidélité c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt une forme de liberté
quand quand on rencontre quelqu'un avec
qui on se sent finalement totalement en
phase qui n'est pas nécessairement le ce
qui n'a pas été nécessairement le cas
avant du tout lorsque vous êtes venus
ici à trois ans presque jour pour jour
vous avez dit j'adore être soumise au
regard d'un pygmalion quelqu'un qui me
construit en fait
et vous pensez qu'avec jean michel j'ai
trouvé ce pygmalion qui va vous
construire non je pense que justement
c'est très différent et c'est pour ça
que moi ce que j'ai senti c'est quelque
chose que je n'ai jamais senti
auparavant et et justement j'ai souvent
j'ai pu me trompe je n'ai rien et je ne
regrette rien parce qu'effectivement
tout ça ça a été une construction
importante pour moi mais le besoin de
pygmalion c'est aussi parfois une façon
dévié ne pas savoir ce qu'on cherche de
ne pas savoir ce qui vous manque et de
trouver à travers le puma lionisme un
semblant de d'équilibré d'harmonie
justement c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas avec jean michel c'est donc
pour moi essentiel parce qu'on part sur
une sur une base de partager nos
passions de base de solutions une
relation c'est évidemment lié à une
notion d' équilibre donc je pense
qu'elle a autant à m'apprendre que j'ai
à lui apprendre
jusque là la veille des pygmalion c'est
vrai nous l'a dit alors ma vie aussi je
me vois pas belle je me vis pas belges
et des troubles avec mon image ça va
mieux là oui mais je vous avais dit
aussi qui à l'époque afin que que saviez
ça provenait safran venait de l'enfance
car évidemment comme toutes les grandes
séquelles qui perdure en tant qu'adulte
et que finalement le monde d'amour que
j'ai pu ressentir à tort ou à raison la
seule façon effectivement de le combler
c'est d'en recevoir est de savoir le
prendre
le vivre le reconnaître et c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui est
notamment en train d'évoluer m'aviez dit
j'aurai finalement plus aimé être une
femme au foyer élever des enfants avoir
un mari qui rentrent le soir
non j'ai tout faire maintenant j'ai
envie de tout faire alors vous disiez à
l'époque que j'arrive pas à être
heureuse j'ai pas les éléments chimiques
qu'il faut aujourd'hui cela aujourd'hui
ça paraît totalement mais tout va tout
va tout va mais parce qu'en fait je
pense que c'est valable pour tout le
monde c'est vrai pour moi en fait je
suis quelqu'un d'assez simple car quel
partir de monde vous avez l'essentiel et
à partir du moment où effectivement il
ya la rencontre avec l'autre il ya
énormément de choses qui s'élimine et il
ya énormément de choses des
problématiques qui s'évanouissent un
bien évidemment puisque d'un seul coup
vous vous vivez à travers un regard qui
exonère totalement le sujet de la
fidélité dans le couple vous
dès que vous n'y croyez pas non c'est
vrai j'ai dit beaucoup beaucoup de
choses jusqu'à 10 en comparable
aujourd'hui vous y croyez en fait tous
les déclarations que j'ai pu faire et
donc toutes celles qui vont me demander
c'est une réponse à la raison pour
laquelle je me suis marié en fait
pleurer comme ça
non pas du tout pour plus répondre ça
pour parsemer réponses sont plus du tout
la même essence est valable surtout je
renie rien du tout tout ce que j'ai pu
dire est que toutes les théories que
j'avais fait échafaudé gelé sont
totalement encore légitime à mes yeux
mais il y avait juste un bémol que je ne
connaissais pas qui est effectivement si
vous rencontrez la personne qui est
fabriqué pour vous au quelqu'un il ya
beaucoup de choses comme je disais tout
à l'heure qui vont disparaître mais donc
effectivement il ya beaucoup de
problèmes de régler beaucoup de choses
et donc la fidélité c'est quelque chose
qui ne se pose plus à partir du monde
enfin quel est le besoin pour un
individu d'aller chez canton bien fidèle
c'est parce que enfin bon je vais parler
pour moi dans ma définition d'infidélité
c'était parce que vraisemblablement
j'allais chercher un petit morceau d'une
personne dans plusieurs et qu'à partir
du moment où j'ai le tout je vais pas
rentrer graissée et repartir sur cd
petits morceaux c'est bien bravo
vous me disiez aussi demandé c'était
meilleur à plusieurs ou le disiez il
faut tout essayer meilleur avec une
femme il faut tout essayer bon là
maintenant j'imagine que aujourd'hui
tout ça c'est s'est passé c'est obsolète
ce qu'a dû que ces voix là c'est
jean-michel maintenant vous poser même
pu toutes ces questions je voudrais même
que vous les posez d'ailleurs moi un
mariage réussi unis pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
le pire c'est quoi avec jean-michel à
part la coiffure
j'aime beaucoup ce à quoi servons là ils
sont un peu longs non vous êtes beaucoup
disputés depuis le 14 mai non